hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation
linking cellular location and patient
prognosis in brain tumors
i am jen woods of labyrinths and i will
be your moderator for today's event
now let's get started before we begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen i
now present today's
speaker dr rebecca erie associate
professor of cell and developmental
biology at vanderbilt university
for a complete biography on dr erie
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr erie you may now begin your
presentation
hello i'm rebecca erie from vanderbilt
university
i'm excited to tell you today about how
obtaining and analyzing
personal protein data has led us to some
new understanding
in brain tumors an area of particular
interest
in my lab so i'm going to tell you about
a few stories today one about
identifying cancer lineage cell
phenotypes within a brain tumor
and then a few stories at the end about
understanding the immune component of
those tumors
and where particular cellular features
are located
within these heterogeneous tumor masses
but first i thought i'd introduce why
are we interested
in using mass cytometry and how has it
been particularly informative for us
in glioblastoma so one of the reasons
that my lab became interested
in using this approach is that when we
think about
everything that's going on within a cell
dna
and rna profiling which have been widely
used in brain tumors and many other
tissues
are certainly very informative but when
we think about
the repertoire of things that a cell is
capable of doing
this information is necessarily
incomplete and so one of our goals was
really to
complement what we had learned and what
the field had learned
at the dna and rna level to better
understand
beyond copy number analysis sequence
analysis
and transcript analysis some of the
things that we really wanted to see
were how cells are dynamically
responding to their neighbors and what
their signaling capability at the
protein level
shown here really is so
many of the things that i'm going to
show you some of the important features
for us
in identifying cells that were of
interest are things like
signaling cascades so phosphorylated
signaling proteins which are shown here
in green with a red modification and so
as you'll see many of the stories that
we're interested in center around things
that need to be measured at the protein
level
in my lab we are particularly interested
in studying brain tumors
and in the research i'm going to tell
you about today we have a special focus
in the most malignant form of primary
brain tumor glioblastoma
so glioblastomas are by far the most
common
tumors that present in the brain that
have
origins within the brain they're about
half of all brain tumors and the huge
majority
of malignant brain tumors
unfortunately although they've been a
heavy focus of study
for many years glioblastoma prognosis
has not improved much
over the past decades what i'm showing
you at the left here is the last major
change to standard of care
for these tumors the introduction of the
alkylating agent temozolomide
in addition to radiotherapy and while
use of this agent does somewhat extend
survival as shown in
this kaplan-meier plot on the left you
can see
that this curve still trends downward
and so many patients have a very poor
prognosis and there's been a huge effort
to try to better understand these tumors
so that we can come up with new ways of
targeting them
in particular there's been an extensive
amount of work to profile dna and rna
changes within these tumors resulting in
their organization into molecular
subclasses that are thought to reflect
some of the
underlying biology in different patients
tumors
and so there are currently three major
uh
subtypes of glioblastoma they're
distinguished majorly
primarily by alterations in growth
factor receptor
gene copy number as well as
transcriptional signatures
that resemble different types of
progenitor cells within the brain
however one ongoing challenge in the
field
is that as illustrated by the smaller
survival plot in the bottom right
there are not large differences yet in
clinical outcome between patients
that have these different subtypes of
glioblastoma
so more work needs to be done to
understand how we can couple
these biological variations and
different subclasses
to features that might be targetable and
might
improve outcome and there are several
reasons why it's been a challenge to
transition these classifications into
understanding that we can use to design
new therapies
uh one of them is a problem that is
common to many solid tumors
glioblastomas as illustrated here in the
cartoon
are complex tumors so they have many um
different cancer lineage cells within
them
cells that uh resemble different stages
of neural stem cell differentiation but
have cancer lineage mutations in them
these tumors are also highly
infiltrative and so there are many
normal cells
within any resected tumor mass that we
study for example
um neurons astrocytes and glia the
resonant cells of the brain there are
also endothelial cells these
tumors are noted to have abnormal
vasculature
and importantly there are many different
types of infiltrating immune cells
and so many of the analyses that i
referenced before
use bulk dna or rna profiling which
while informative
are difficult in allowing us to see the
cell to cell heterogeneity
within these masses and this is perhaps
easily illustrated in one example piece
of data from our group
so these are cells from a glioblastoma
tumor
which underwent copy number alteration
analysis so this would be considered
potentially
a classical subtype of glioblastoma
and based primarily on having an
estimated copy number of the egfr
gene of 22 versus the normally expected
two however when we look at this biaxial
plot of s100b
and astrocyte marker and egfr the
protein that we would expect to be
highly expressed across this tumor
when you look at this contour plot of
all of the events where we measured egfr
protein expression on the cell surface
what i hope you can see is that although
there are certainly some cells that
express egfr protein
a huge majority of cells in the tumor
actually don't have
very high protein level expression and
so again
copying number alterations while
informative and helping us think about
the biology of the tumor
haven't told us the whole story yet
so some of the things that we are
interested in understanding in my lab
and the reason that we developed the
tools i'm going to introduce
today are that we wanted to understand
these heterogeneous
mixtures of cells and also how they vary
across patients and so one of the
driving questions that
has interested my lab and collaborators
over the last few years
are one how can we find highly malignant
phenotypes across glioblastoma
so how can we find the most aggressive
cells the ones that are driving
recurrence which might not be the
majority of the tumor mass
and whose abundance might vary across
patients
and also how can we do discovery work in
smaller cohorts of patients so for
example clinical trials
might require hundreds of patients but
for
discovery work in biology we might need
to work with smaller groups of patients
in the study i'm going to show you we
looked at a discovery cohort
of 28 and so how can we leverage
all of the information that we get from
approaches like mass cytometry where we
have millions of cells
and lots of data on specific parameters
that we measured
to figure out which of these parameters
help us find
the most bad actors the cells that are
driving the worst outcomes
and then identify their targetable
features
so the approach that we elected to use
as a complement to many studies using
single cell sequencing of the dna and
rna levels
is mass cytometry or cytosk
and one of the reasons that we were
particularly excited to use this is that
it allows us to measure many features
we selected a panel of about 40
different parameters
based on our knowledge of brain tumor
biology and some of the
previous genetic analyses in the field
and
it lets us look at millions of cells so
we're really well powered
to try to find rare subsets that might
be a minority
of the primary tumor when it comes from
the operating room to our lab
so in this cartoon schematic i'm showing
you a general workflow that we developed
and published together with our
collaborators in the irish lab at
vanderbilt
in the study i'm talking about today all
of the patients had
idh wild-type glioblastoma the most
common molecular classification of
glioblastoma
and all of these are primary tumors
meaning that this is before
this is from the initial resection
before patients undergo temozolomide and
radiation therapy
so when tumors are resected in the
operating room
within an hour they come to our
laboratory and are
viably dissociated and viably
cryopreserved
using protocols that we have since
published so that we have millions of
cells
archived in liquid nitrogen that we can
then
bring out and study through
immunostaining and mass cytometry
so we first developed a panel of
antibodies to allow us to find
immune endothelial and other
infiltrating cells and then to focus in
on the presumed cancer lineage cells
that are the majority of the cells
in these samples and then in order to
try to identify
cellular phenotypes in an unbiased way
we developed a workflow called
rapid which i'm going to dissect for you
in more detail now
so some of the reasons that we were
really excited about rapid
are that one a couple it couples the per
cell
data that we're able to obtain using
mass cytometry
to continuous features like
things that we measure in the clinic so
for example
progression free survival which would be
measured in days or weeks
and then overall survival which in
glioblastoma
still has a median at a time length of
about 15
months and this is something that was
relatively unique to this tool there are
other tools for analyzing
high dimensional data but they often
require either that you have prior
knowledge
of the normal tissue lineage hierarchy
or normal samples for comparison
this is often difficult to obtain as
samples of normal brain
are not readily available in our case
or the tools require that you in advance
assign your tumors or other samples that
you're measuring
to specific categories and in
glioblastoma we really wanted
to take an unsupervised approach where
we didn't
know outcome before the cells were
analyzed so we wanted to analyze
all of these samples together and then
identify
in an unsupervised way which cells
were associated with bad outcome and
that is what rapid does
so i will take you through the workflow
in more detail
but in brief as you can see in the
bottom half of this slide
we took over 131 880 glioblastoma cells
from
28 patients uh used optimized
clustering to assign all of those cells
to clusters based on the parameters that
we measured
and then asked which of those clusters
are
meaningfully associated with outcomes so
if a patient has very high abundance of
cells that fall into
a particular group does is their outcome
better or worse and in this study we
were able to identify
both glioblastoma negative prognostic
cells whose abundance
is predictive of especially bad outcome
and glioblastoma positive prognostic
cells
whose abundance indicates an especially
long
overall survival so
now i'd like to take you through how
this workflow works and some of the
interesting things that we found about
the biology of these cells
first we in this case wanted to
computationally exclude immune immune
and endothelial cells
not because we're not interested in them
i have a few bits of a story on
the immune compartment of these tumors
coming up in a minute
but because for this initial study we
were particularly interested
in cells that are primarily cancer
lineage cells
so after excluding immune and
endothelial cells on a per patient basis
so here
removing the orange blue and red
islands that are marked on the right
hand part of the slide
we then took all the other events in
each
patient's map and concatenated them
together
as shown in this cartoon format here so
here
we took what we're calling glioblastoma
cells so non-immune non-endothelial
um pooled the data together for all of
the 28 patients
with equal sampling from each and then
perform dimensionality reduction to give
us the map that is shown on the right
rabbit then uses optimized flow some
clustering so self-organizing maps
to identify cell populations and this is
another point in the workflow
where we really wanted the choice of
cluster number
to be determined in an unbiased way
rather than having the researcher try to
hypothesize how many groups of cells
might be present
in the sample because at this time point
in these diverse tumors we really didn't
know how many phenotypes to expect
so one of the things that the rapid
workflow does is it iteratively tests
different numbers of clusters in the
flowsome algorithm
and identifies the right number to use
to minimize
intracluster variation while still
having representative clusters and so in
this case we ended up with 43 different
clusters detected by flosam
rapid will then test as i said for each
of these clusters
whether it's abundance in an individual
patient and across the patient cohort
is associated with a hazard ratio that
is above
one meaning that as the abundance of
this population increases across
patients
the risk of death is greater or
whether it was associated with a hazard
ratio less than one
which is shown in blue on the t sneak
plot on the far
right meaning that if the abundance of
this phenotype in an individual
patient's tumor is higher
the risk of death is proportionately
lower and so
doing several iterative testing steps
that i'm alighting here to test for
stability of these clusters and
reproducibility across
multiple analysis runs we identified
as i said glioblastoma negative
prognostic cells which are shown in red
on this map and you'll notice are all
located together on one side of the map
and glioblastoma positive prognostic
cells which are shown in blue and
predominantly on the right side of the
map
and what was particularly rewarding for
us is that if we then
again in an automated way classify the
patients in the cohort as having a high
proportion of either gnp in red or gpp
cells in blue and then look at overall
survival you can see that
indeed patients who have a very high
proportion
of the gnp phenotype in their tumor as
shown in the red
curve on the left hand side here and
have a much shorter overall survival
meaning that their tumors are especially
aggressive and conversely patients with
a high fraction of gpp cells in their
tumor
this is the blue curve on the right hand
plot have better
than average overall survival and you
can see this in the blue curve which
pushes out further to the right so this
was really exciting to us because
these kinds of survival differences as i
noted at the beginning
have not been easy to parse out in other
types of data at the genomic dna or rna
level so seeing something that
stratified survival
was very exciting to us because it gives
us an opportunity to better understand
the biology of these tumors and think
about how to target them
when we look at the individual channels
that were measured this is a subset of
the features that were
identified as enriched on negative
prognostic
or positive prognostic cells and then
compare them against the rest of the
sample which is shown in the gray
histograms below
you can see that the phenotypes of the
negative and positive prognostic
cells are different principally
we see a lot of expression of the
stem-like marker sox2
in negative prognostic cells and so that
histogram is further to the right
and interestingly they also express this
protein s100b which is typically a
marker of
non-stem more mature cells so these
cancer cells have a very mixed phenotype
in which they somewhat resemble um stem
cells which are quite rare in the normal
brain
but then also resemble mature cells and
this is something that we wouldn't
typically
see in this normal tissue and
as you look at the right hand side of
the slide and look at these histograms
in red
you might also notice that these cells
in the negative prognostic population
are particularly distinguished by having
high levels of many phosphorylated
proteins
that is they have very active signaling
through multiple pathways downstream of
some of the growth factor receptors that
are commonly
mutated in glioblastoma although
interestingly they don't have
particularly high levels
of many of the growth factor receptors
themselves so something is keeping these
pathways
relatively elevated and now we would
like to know what
beyond looking at this on the per
channel
analysis of histograms we were also able
to use a statistic
developed by the irish lab at vanderbilt
marker enrichment modeling
to put a human and machine readable
label on each of these populations
so at the top i'm showing you the label
for the negative prognostic cells
and if we look next to the up arrow for
total protein denoted by p
you can see that these cells as i said
are especially enriched for s100b
and sox2 they're also specifically
lacking some other
important proteins that denote different
brain lineages
as well as the epidermal growth factor
receptor and
if we look at the signaling signature
denoted by s lower down in the box
you can see that these negative
prognostic cells are also
specifically enriched for signaling
through stat 3
s6 and stat 5 suggesting that they have
a pro-survival
signaling program that is active and
conversely when we look
at the label for the glioblastoma
positive prognostic cells
although these cells are quite enriched
for the epidermal growth factor receptor
which was a very unexpected outcome
they are also distinguished by a general
lack of
phosphorylated signaling proteins
when we go back to look at individual
tumors and this is a feature
that i really like of having the per
cell per patient data available to us
we can also look at individual tumors
and see that they reflect
some of these overall phenotypes so for
example lco2 which is on the left
has a very high proportion of cells that
as shown at the top in the t-sne plots a
cluster on the left-hand side of the
group
map so over in the negative prognostic
area
we can also quantify this and the
percentages that are shown at the
right in a red box and
when we look at individual measured
features we can see
in the heat on the t-sne plots below
that
these cells are and the cells in this
patient
are higher for many of the parameters
that distinguish negative prognostic
cells
and the converse is the case for w11
at the right and if you look at
pfs and os which are shown near the top
the outcome for each patient
you can see again that the negative
prognostic cells being abundant
is generally a negative indicator for
overall survival
interestingly as i mentioned at the
beginning although we excluded
the immune cells from the rapid analysis
in the discovery of gnp
and gpp we of course were then
interested in seeing
whether the cancer lineage or
glioblastoma cell features related
to what we saw in the immune compartment
and one interesting observation right
away
was that glutamine negative prognostic
abundant tumors so gnp
high patients shown in red at the left
have a higher have a lower percentage
excuse me
of uh cd45 positive infiltrating
immune cells so immune cell abundance is
much
lower in the negative prognostic cells
raising many interesting hypotheses
about
what the interaction between this cell
phenotype
and the immune response to the tumor is
and conversely again
gliama positive prognostic high tumors
in patients had a higher percentage of
cd45 positive
immune infiltrate so having all of these
machine readable labels in hand and
having all the high dimensional data
was fantastic for us for being able to
do additional ongoing discovery work in
these tumors and to understand these
phenotypes
but we also wanted to think about how
might this be translatable to approaches
that neuropathologists typically use
and so one of the things we were very
interested in testing is that now that
we've been able
to measure many parameters and identify
the ones that are most
selectively expressed on negative and
positive prognostic cells
can we use that to find
a more pared-down way to stratify
patients in a larger number of samples
so for example can we use an
imaging-based approach
to then identify gnp-like
and gpp-like tumors and still see
effects on survival similar to what we
saw in the high dimensional
suspension analyses of these solid
tumors
so taking these labels on the left
marker enrichment modeling
and looking at the aggregate data shown
on the right as a biaxial plot for egfr
and s100b
one thing that we noticed is that these
two parameters
are inversely correlated both in the mem
labels and then when we look at the
biaxial plot of the individual data
samples tend to have a lot of egfr
or a lot of s100b but fewer cells have
both and so we hypothesized that as
these were the most enriched parameters
we might be able to use them
to design a much more simplified
staining protocol
to identify tumors that had gnp or
gpp-like cells
and so what i'm showing you here is
analysis
of a tissue microarray that has an
additional cohort of 73 patients
beyond the 28 that we studied in
suspension
and across the top you can see as we
stand for many of the features that are
enriched
in gnp or gpp cells that we were able to
detect them
and to classify patients as low medium
or high
for these parameters looking solely
at egfr and s100b at the bottom
we were able to design a stratification
scheme
based on the marker enrichment modeling
labels that i showed you before
to classify patients as gnp-like
gpp-like or low for both and
looking at the right if we then look at
survival in those patients
looking at the red curve of survival
over time
and then the blue curve you can see that
even using a different platform
and a simplified approach we're able to
use the information from our siteoff
analyses
to predict especially short or long
outcome across the patients included in
this tissue microarray
and so this is suggested to us that this
can be turned into something that can be
applied more broadly across large
cohorts of patients
allowing us to think more about
additional parameters
but of course in my lab the more numbers
we can put on something the better
and so the other future direction that
we are just beginning and really
interested to pursue
um is to try to analyze all of these
parameters simultaneously on the tissue
microarray
so one thing that those of you who do a
lot of imaging might be
considering as you look at this slide is
that it can be very challenging across
individual sections
to then come up with a unified score for
each
tissue core on a microarray so we have
to do each one of the columns that i'm
showing you in a separate imaging run
and then try to assign a score that we
can put
back with the scores for all the other
parameters
to classify the patient so wouldn't it
be nice if we could measure everything
together and that's something that we're
working on now
together with the brisket center with
imaging mass cytometry
at washington university st louis and so
one thing we're excited to do going
forward
is to take all the parameters that we
used on dissociated tumors and
suspension
and apply them across this tissue
microarray and see whether having
more information gives us better
classification
of the patients included in the tissue
microarray cohort
and as this as these data really
illustrate
especially in my lab you know some of
the questions that we want to answer
requires spatial information and so
some of the things that i'm going to
tell you about now focus on both
tumor location within the brain how does
that affect
the features of cancer cells in the
immune cells within the tumor
and then how do we think about taking
some of the phenotypes that we've
discovered in suspension and figuring
out where they localize
within individual tumors or across
individual tumors
and this is something that my lab has
been interested in for a long time
perhaps because we study a niche that
has a lot of specialized
cytoarchitectural features so for
example
if you look at the right the image on
the right here
you can see this is the human brain
stem cell niche with stem cells labeled
in green
and recently born young neurons in red
and simply i think looking at this image
brings home the point that these cells
have very different
shapes which connect to their biological
function
they're located in different parts of
this niche so some of them are
right up next to the cerebrospinal fluid
the open space at the top
but they also extend a long process in
green
down to touch vasculature that underlies
this niche itself and so thinking about
how these cells contact each other
and how that influences their phenotype
is going to be
an important question going forward and
we knew that we wanted to investigate
this because we had some clues from the
clinical literature
including studies by a neurosurgery
fellow in my lab
akshay kumar mystery so mystery
independently had become interested in
this question
of uh when glioblastoma presents in the
brain
does it matter whether or not it
contacts specific structures
within the brain and this was building
on some earlier data
in a small number of cases from studies
at other institutions but
mystery was able to build two cohorts
of about 200 patients each to
ask this question in a statistically
meaningful way and one of the things
that he found that we were really
excited about
and so mystery chose to classify
patients into
one of four categories based on their
mris and some examples are shown at the
left
so about 50 of patients on their initial
diagnosis so when they first
enter the clinic with glioblastoma have
a tumor
that contacts the lateral ventricles
and these are the sort of black
butterfly shape in the center
of the brain and it's an important area
to us
because one of the two stem cell niches
of the brain is located next to the
lateral ventricles
so about half of patients when they come
in have a tumor that is contacting the
stem cell niche
and half of them do not
in addition a smaller subset of patients
as shown in the top right mri
have a tumor that contacts the other
stem major stem cell niche of the brain
the dentate gyrus and so one of
mystery's key observations was not just
to say
do patients have a tumor that contacts
the lateral ventricle niche
or not but also to say is there
something special about the lateral
ventricle niche versus the other stem
cell niche
and to summarize uh quite a bit of work
classifying mris on his point
on his part what he was able to show is
that
as shown in the survival curve on the
right
if a patient's tumor contacts the
lateral ventricle stem cell niche
but not the other one that is known to
exist in the brain
those patients have shorter overall
survival so a worse outcome and that's
illustrated by the red
curve and the kaplan-meier plot on the
right
and he then did quite a bit of work to
think about
well did this connect to any other known
predictors of
outcome such as the size of the tumor
the ability of the surgeon to resect it
or bulk dna and transcriptomic profiles
and the short answer is that
none of those things explain the
difference that he has observed
raising some interesting questions about
what biology might be behind
the differing outcomes then so
is the stem cell niche or the cerebral
spinal fluid next to it somehow
influencing the biology of the tumor and
can we see this difference using some of
the tools that we had already developed
fortunately in the viably cryo preserved
cohort where we had done sight off
analysis
when we looked at survival relative to
stem cell niche contact
we again saw the same pattern so we
already had a representative cohort in
hand
and multiple people in my group as well
as the irish lab at vanderbilt have
begun
exploring what might be different in the
cancer lineage cells within
ventricle contacting tumors as well as
the immune cells within them
first um justine sinev a phd graduate of
my lab
was able to use an existing tool called
citrus
to identify clusters of cellular
phenotypes that are enriched
in non-contacting tumors versus
ventricle contacting tumors
and here citrus in fact worked very well
for us because
unlike at the start of the rapid
analysis where we wanted to be
unsupervised
here we had one clear criterion that
allowed us to separate the tumors into
two groups
based on their uh mri contact
information
so we found a cluster of cells that is
enriched in non-contacting tumors
and excitingly the protein
expression levels of cells that fall
within this cluster
very closely resemble the glioma
positive prognostic phenotype suggesting
to
us that ventricular contact in the
previously identified more
favorable cellular phenotype might go
together
and you can see this by comparing the
citrus results which are in the top row
cluster a is in purple and everything
else in the sample is in gray
and then the individual histograms of
positive prognostic cells from the prior
study rapid study beneath
what i hope you can see is that the
distribution of these features is very
similar between the two analyses
and intriguingly in addition to seeing
some differences within the cancer
lineage cells
when we look at the immune component of
stem cell niche
contacting or distant tumors we also see
and some very interesting differences
that suggest possible future directions
in immunobiology
so this is the work of todd barcoviak a
shared postdoc between my group and the
irish lab at vanderbilt
and in brief todd has analyzed the
infiltrating immune component
within all of the resected tumors that
we had previously
analyzed for features within the
non-immune
endothelial compartment so looking at
the immune cells
and plotting uh the data from multiple
patients together as shown across the
top
um todd was able to compare
all of the data together as shown in the
contoured disney plot
at the left and then separate out only
ventricle contacting tumors which are in
blue in the contour
the next contour plot and non-contacting
tumors shown in the red
and what i hope you can see when we
overlay those plots and then when we
computationally seek for
clusters that are enriched and only one
or the other shown at the right
is that there are some cells that are
predominantly
seen in contacting or non-contacting
tumors
i.e that there are areas where these
maps don't overlap
and using rapid analysis again
on these data todd was again able to
identify
clusters of cells with similar
phenotypes here shown
either in red or in green
that are associated with especially good
or especially bad
outcome in patients and i'm just showing
you two examples here
where patients are dichotomized based on
whether they have high or low abundance
for some of these immune cell phenotypes
and for example when we look at subset
17
shown in red and separate out patients
that are abundant for that cluster
that would fall primarily in the stem
cell niche contacting
classification we see that those
patients do worse
so these data collectively suggest that
stem cell niche contact has a really
profound effect
both on the cancer cell phenotype and
on the immune cell phenotype and that
going forward we're really interested
in finding ways to couple what we can
see on mri
which is a routine visualization that is
done
for glioblastoma patients to information
that might help us think about
what treatments might work best on those
patients tumors
so going forward i told you before that
spatial information is important and we
just spent some time discussing
how location within the brain has a
significant influence
on tumor prognosis as well as the cells
that are found within the tumor
but in addition i wanted to take a
moment to highlight where
imaging mass cytometry and thinking
about cell to cell variation and
distribution
within the tumor is starting to help us
think about
how particular phenotypes cluster
together within a tumor
and how we can identify um cell to cell
variation and understand the biology
and spatial organization of these tumors
so i have two example imaging mass
cytometry cases
uh one again focused on glioblastoma and
then a second study
of subpentable giant cell astrocytomas a
different brain tumor
where stem cell niche contact and
location
is also very important but we know less
about the signaling variation within an
individual tumor than we do about
glioblastoma
and also less about its differentiation
state
so to do this we spent a significant
amount of time between
in my lab developing and validating a
brain-centered
imaging panel i'm showing you one
example here where we made custom
conjugates
of an antibody against for example
phosphovimentin
which is shown in red at the far left
and marks
dividing progenitors in the early brain
as well as
a subset of brain tumor cells that
resemble these progenitors
so on the left you can see the expected
staining pattern this is the antibody
before we conjugated it to a metal
you can see overall brain architecture
in blue
and then the merged image and then we
always after conjugation to a metal
will restain the same control sample and
that's what you're seeing on the far
right
to make sure that we see the same
distribution we were expecting
based on the original clone so
after some optimization and selection of
parameters of interest based on our
biological knowledge
we began staining with a trial panel
that contains
antigens that overlap with the rapid
story that i told you about before
as well as some other lineage-specific
transcription factors and phosphor
proteins that were particularly of
interest to us
and when we began staining glioblastoma
samples
we got images like the following so this
is a single
glioblastoma patient's case and a subset
of the antigens that we tried
you can see phosphostat3 tyrosine 705 in
yellow
and one thing that you might notice is
that
we see what appears to be a non-random
distribution of signaling here where we
might have clusters
of cells signaling together so we're
very interested to use some of the tools
developed by other presenters of this
conference
to push our understanding of that
localization further
and then ultimately do some mechanistic
testing of the hypotheses we get from
these images
we also we're really excited to be able
to have lots of parameters
simultaneously so this is another
set of antigens on the same piece of
tissue
and this staining this pilot staining
was done at king's college london guys
hospital so
a special thank you to them um and
some of the things that are of interest
to us are that in addition to the
clusters of phosphostat iii that i
previously indicated
you can also see that we see phosphoerc
in the bright magenta
in many spots throughout the tumor but
again located in
clusters that we think will be
interesting to explore when thinking
about local signaling
we have been able to use tools such as
histacat
and then marker enrichment modeling to
take these images and assign each
segmented cell within the image to a
particular cluster
and then for us using marker enrichment
modeling on these data is especially
helpful in finding
clusters of interest so for example when
we take the image on the left
and then you analyze the data in
histocat giving us the dimensionality
reduction plot at right
and we can single out clusters like the
one in dark red on the far
right cluster 13 and c in the mem label
in the listing at the right that this
cluster for example is especially high
for phosphostat5 so
phosphostat5 is specifically enriched in
that cluster
you can see that a little better here
when we look at the heat for
phosphostat5
on the same map or on the original image
and we are particularly interested in
these cells because
phosphostat5 is one of the driving
markers of the negative prognostic
phenotype and glioblastoma
so we're very excited going forward to
think about
distance from the stem cell niche and
other features that can be really nicely
measured
using imaging approaches and then taking
those data
and applying all the quantitative
analysis tools that we've already
developed
for suspension cytosk so in my last few
minutes i wanted to show you one of the
other brain tumor types
that the lab is really interested in
studying these are periventricular brain
tumors so they present next to the same
stem cell niche i was talking about
before
but these are a really interesting
contrast point to highly malignant
glioblastoma
because they're benign and because they
present very early in life
and children with a disorder termed
tuberous sclerosis complex
so these tumors are of interest in part
because
their origins are somewhat poorly
understood but also
from a quantitative biology perspective
they're interesting because
they're quite poorly defined they're
described as having
a mixed glio neuronal phenotype which
essentially means that you can see
markers of nearly
every brain lineage in them they're
known to have high
mtor complex 1 signaling because
tuberous sclerosis complex is a disease
where
regulators of amtor are mutated but
beyond that we have
relatively scant information on how to
distinguish them
from other benign brain tumor types and
other tumor types that present in the
brain where mtor signaling for example
is also altered
so one of the things that we are
particularly interested in doing moving
forward
is using both suspension and imaging
mass cytometry
to get a much more quantitative
description of what the cells in these
tumors look like and again what are some
selectively enriched
targetable features so these tumors are
relatively rarely resected but
fortunately through collaboration with
the head of the tsc clinic at vanderbilt
kevin s we do have access to some of
these samples
and i'm showing you imaging of one of
them here um so this is again
um one suboppendable giant cell
astrocytoma tumor that's been stained
with our pilot panel of the antibodies
we're particularly interested in things
like phosphos6
shown in red here because it indicates
high end to our activity
as well as lineage markers like ttf1 or
nkx 2.1
which would tell us something about the
region of origin
of this tumor if we look at an
additional
subset of the antigens we can also see
some
other classic readouts of mtorc1 such as
phospho4abp1 which is shown in red
and one of the things that we were
interested to see right away is that
again
this is not evenly distributed
throughout the tumor we might
hypothesize
because these patients are
carrying a mutation in a regulator of
antarctic one that every cell within the
tumor
might have high m torque one activity
and that there would not be a particular
distribution
but it doesn't appear that that is the
case instead if we
take this these images uh segment them
and use histicat and mem as in the
previous approach i was discussing
you can see that cells are assigned to
clusters here indicated by colors
that are not evenly distributed
throughout the tumor
and what was particularly interesting to
us is that
when we look at some of our key markers
of interest such as for example
sox2 a marker of stemness and
phosphorous 6
a marker of high m torque 1 activity
what we see a little bit contrary to
expectations in the field
is that while there is one cluster of
cells shown in cyan
that has very high stox2 expression
relative to everything else
it is actually not the same cluster as
the one that has the highest mtor
complex one activity which is indicated
in red
and so we're going to be thinking a lot
about how do these two features which
were thought to generally be
present in the same cells actually
relate to each other within these tumors
and interestingly as we have gone back
uh to close the loop
into suspension mass cytometry analyses
of
samples from tsc patients we see again a
similar pattern
and so in my last data slide i'm showing
you suspension mass cytometry uh
individual parameters at the top and
then the t-sne analysis at the bottom
with heat for individual markers
we've been able to go back in and see
well we indeed have
a lot of cells within resected masses
from patients that have
a lot of sucks to expression as shown in
the bottom right
those socks to high cells or the cells
that have the highest stocks to
are not actually the same events that
are very very high
for phosphorylated s6 which is shown in
the
very bottom right here and you can see
when looking at the heat on the t-sne
plot that one island is very high for
phosphorous 6
but not for sox too and in fact that
upper island
uh bears the marker of expression of a
different
uh lineage progression marker uh sox10
so some of the central findings that
i've tried to highlight today
are that particularly in glioblastoma
where
transcriptomic and other genomic
analyses have
not yet allowed us to stratify patients
into different groups based on outcome
instead measurements at the protein
level particularly
including phosphorylation events have
helped us find prognostic subgroups of
cells that we can investigate further
we did a lot of this through the custom
workflow termed rapid which has now been
published
but we can also using the information
from rapid
come up with simple stratification
assays and go back to other types of
high dimensional data
and ask how our findings for example in
fixed tissue
compare to suspension um ultimately
we're very excited to find too that
stem cell niche contact changes the
cancer cell and immune cell features and
is linked to some of the differences in
prognosis that we found before
and importantly these phenotypes are not
uniformly distributed through the tissue
and so going back and forth between what
we can
discover in suspension and in fixed
tissue has been an incredibly useful
tool for us
so i'll conclude just by thanking the
small army of excellent collaborators
who joined
in on this work especially jonathan
irish
the director of the cancer and
immunology corps and the mass cytometry
center of excellence in addition to his
own lab
our close collaborator vivian gamma who
is a stem cell biology expert
kevin s the head of the tsc clinic at
vanderbilt
as well as his colleague carrie fu the
three neurosurgeons who worked
diligently with us over years to collect
patient samples
the graduate students and post-docs in
the erie irish gamma and s
labs as well as the excellent staff shin
below
and the neuropathologist brett mobley
and
neuro surgery fellow akshay kumar
mystery who really
took the lead on making sure that we had
all the annotated clinical data needed
and finally of course i would also like
to thank all of our funders
including the individual donors and
patients and their families
and i will stop there and take any
questions
thank you dr erie for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
let's get started our first question is
how do you know which ones are gpp
versus gnp
at the beginning okay
can you hear me just let me make sure
first great
okay so thank you for that question um
so
i think what you're asking is how can we
call
individual patients or individual cells
as being part of
the gpp versus gnp
uh populations or whether a patient is
called as low as
low or high for gbp and gnp let me start
with the cells
so one of the things that was really
important to us in designing rapid is
actually that
we wanted to be naive to a lot of that
information when starting the analysis
and so we actually did not know what the
important features for gnp
and gpp were going to be until the
analysis was complete
one of the things that we really like
about rapid is that you can essentially
give it your patient
siteof information so however many
patients you've included usually around
25 is useful for starter cohorts
and so you take the fcs files or the i'm
the imd files and um
feed the data the data into rapid
together
with the in this case uh survival
uh times for all of the patients so you
start without knowing for example which
patients were good or bad
outcome necessarily and then
most of the remaining steps are done in
an automated fashion
so the gnp and gpp phenotypes and then
the labels that define them
are generated as part of the rapid
workflow
and so the short answer is uh we did not
know
at the beginning um which
cell uh phenotypes and which features
were going to be the most important ones
and that's where having a lot of
parameters to be able to analyze was
really helpful because we were able to
cast a very
wide net for example um we might have
hypothesized based on the literature
that um expression of other stem-like
features like cd133 would be very
important
for identifying prognostically
meaningful cells but it turns out
we measured that along with eight other
you know things associated with stemness
and only sox2
was selectively enriched on the gnp
population so i hope that helps cancer
something about the cells and then
in terms of how patients for example are
assigned to
being high or low for a particular
self-phenotype so they have high
abundance or low abundance that is also
done
in a largely automated fashion based on
the distribution of abundances
within the cohort so again we try not to
create an artificial cut off we try to
find it in a statistically determined
way
okay thank you for that dr erie
next question since gnp
is inversely proportional to immune
cells does the same apply to gpp
in other words is immune cell enrichment
and tumors a good predictor of survival
if yes how do you explain mesence gbm's
survival which is heavily
infiltrated with immune cells right so
um i can see the speaker as familiar
with some of the gbm literature
so um let me answer the gbp
question first um so
yes gpp high patients have a somewhat
proportionately higher
immune infiltration and that's just
looking at total
cd45 positive cells um
so well it somewhat went along with
survival in our smaller discovery cohort
i think there's a more complex story
which you're getting at with the
question about glioblastomas that are
transcriptionally classified
as mesenchymal are thought to have a lot
of immune infiltration
and that's based partially i think on
immunostaining studies of tmas and
partially on transcript level
analysis um so i guess
what i would say and what i think some
of todd's data that i briefly covered
demonstrated is that although the the
proportion of immune cells in the tumor
potentially has a small uh and has some
influence on survival it is definitely
not the whole story
and so it's much more important what the
exact complement of immune cells within
the tumor
is and beyond that i would also say just
because
you know t cells or specific
subpopulations are present
does not actually guarantee that they
are capable of carrying out their
you know their normally intended
function so i think it's going to be
really important to look at the
um ability of those cells to actually
mount an anti-tumor response
and some of the signaling pathways that
would indicate that activation is
happening
um so i think while
cd45 positive gives us a clue that
something is going on
we we need to explore it more deeply so
okay and oh i'm sorry can i also just
that
the other thing to keep in mind is that
when we try to look for protein-level
proxies
of the transcriptomic classification um
so for example
you would use uh transcriptomic or
genomic alterations to call a tumor
as mesenchymal or another subclass and
we don't always see that that perfectly
matches
expression of those things like cd44 or
matte for the mesenchymal subclass
at the protein level and so i also think
um one of the things that will be really
interesting as we go forward
is to go back and retrospectively
use transcriptomic and genomic
classification on tumors that we know
have gnp
or gpp to try to figure out how those
categories fit together
so okay our next question
i see hla dr plus cd45 minus cells
what are those in tsne plots and cd64
plus cd4 plus cells can you please
comment on that
yes so todd the generator of that data
is actually in the audience and i have
asked him as well
so one thing that i think is important
to point out about the particular t-sne
plot in question
is that all of the events that are on
that plot have already been gated for
being cd45
positive i.e we've already pulled out
all of the immune cells and so
when we display the heat for 45
on that t-sne plot they're going to look
very low when in fact it's
that the range is uh much narrower than
you might think
so that particular population we think
is cd45 low hle dr
positive microglia and then on the other
side
the cd4 cd64 are we think are
macrophages
um and i'm sure todd would be happy to
talk about this more
offline if you would like okay great
next question is which is the experience
using any of these markers to follow
patients after the tumor has been
removed in order to check their
prognosis
so if we use any of these
to follow patients so all of the
analyses that i showed
in the rapid workflow are analyzing
tumors
at the initial resection so this is the
tumor is resected
then the patients in this case underwent
standard of care
treatment so we do have um
information both about time to
recurrence of the tumor so progression
free survival which i didn't have time
to talk
about as well as overall survival
so in our case and in what i was able to
show today
we were able to test
how well the combination of markers that
identify gnp and gpp cells
um predict um outcome for the patients
and when we did the tissue microarray
staining that i showed a little bit
later
the part of the point of that was to try
to say can we pull out some of the most
highly enriched markers and use them
to stratify outcome in an independent
cohort so trying to get more at this
predictive question
what i think will be really interesting
to do
going forward that would take this a
little further is to see
when you look at recurrent tumors
do they converge on say a more gnp-like
phenotype so can we learn something
about
what tumors look like post-treatment or
which of these populations are
especially
refractory to standard of care or
investigational treatments
i think that's what the questioner is
getting at but please let me know if you
have a follow up
okay we have time for one more question
how much time does it take to collect
data from a core using imc
so i i'm going to say that this actually
i
could probably talk about in the ask the
expert session this afternoon or dr
bowden miller cred if you don't mind i'd
like to answer the one after that i see
yes is rapid easily translatable to
other diseases and populations
and then a second question about can you
use it on single cell transcriptomics so
first we specifically designed rapid
because we wanted something that would
be translatable to other diseases and
cell populations
and in fact in the paper we actually
tested it on one of dr davis's
who spoke earlier this morning one of
her data sets and we're independently
able to
find the same some of the same
phenotypes that they had shown
where predictive outcomes so we know
that it can translate to other
cytoske data sets quite well and
the intent is that it should be is that
it is modular and can be applied to lots
of other
single cell data types where you have a
continuous measurement
that you want to that you want to use
that could be
patient outcome in days or weeks it
could be time to relapse
it could even be percent immune
infiltrate so the idea is that
um anything where you have that kind of
continuous data
and a sort of medium-sized
investigational single cell data set you
might be able to use this approach
okay thank you again dr erie for your
time and for your
important research before we go i'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today
questions submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
as a reminder please visit the fluidine
booths in the exhibit hall to interact
with representatives
and gather collateral into your virtual
briefcases for later review
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through september of 2021.
until next time goodbye